Mother's Day is approaching and the
channel wants to pay homage to those women
who work hard to support
their families, each one with their own style, each
one in a different way, but in the end with
the heart of a mother who gives
everything for her  children come with me to learn
the story of valeria
gay below my name is valeria kurt
and i am the state director of
school options nevadas
and being a mother logically within all
my titles and the things that i think i have
done good things with my life i think i
have  The best thing I've ever done and the most
beautiful project I've had has been to be
blessed with my son. It's the most
wonderful thing.
I finally knew love. I think I
was very much in love with myself and my husband,
but later we agreed that we love
our son more than we  We love
ourselves, we have to be
multifaceted and no mother is
me.  or
realizing that the most difficult job was
once a mother I said my god
now I understand and I understand why many
women if they want to stay at
home on record there are moms who choose to
stay at home because of their circumstances
my respects to them because they don't  It is an
easy job and I had
a slightly different circumstance in
which I decided to continue my
professional career and my husband decided to support me.
Being a mother is a job, one of the
most beautiful jobs
but at the same time one of the most difficult
because you are training  to the next
generation of your family and you always
want to do the best and there are many
sometimes there is also a lot of guilt and there are days
that for example my son looks at me and says
hey you didn't play with me and I have to
apologize and do the 10 minutes and
the  15 minutes to go play with him
because for him the most important thing is not
that I read to him, it's not that I taught him, it's
that I play with him and be part of his
process. I have to sit in  zoom for
many hours and we talk with different
strategists at the national level we talk about the
state of education it depends on
every day they are different after 10 o'clock on
a Monday from Monday to Wednesday I have to
take my son to school I have an
office now too and  I take my
computer but it depends on the day because
we plan events
and it depends on the situation, I said it is
a legislative session we are following the
legislature of the days that I have to
listen to the education committees I
feel for now watch the videos and see
what they are saying to  analyze and
understand what proposals are happening at
the state level I would like to say that there is
a balance but
there are days that
just as you see me very well groomed from
above and in Beijing I work all day
almost always so we are fabulous
we are wonderful and that the great  work they
do and that sometimes we have to go through
circumstances that are a little more
difficult as mothers, whether you are a
working mother or  I am a single mother
but the most important thing is always to
put your children first. I also do not
want them to feel guilty because
they will have to work because it is the
reality that we have to
live and we have to bring a salary to
our homes but take 15 minutes
when you pick them up from school and
ask them how their day was and if they
tell you well
tell me what you did ask different
questions so that they sit down and
learn to communicate with you reported
to and it's nothing in spanish
natalia lancellotti